let's give ourselves a little bit more
food for thought on this labor versus
capital question so like we've mentioned
many many many times in order to produce
anything you need a little bit of both
or you maybe need a lot of both you need
labor and and you need and you need
capital and so the question is as you
produce that output as you produce that
output or I guess you could say that you
produce this this this this aggregate
this this product how do you decide how
much of it goes to labor and how much of
it goes to capital well one way to think
about it is which resource has more
leverage if you go back to the Gilded
Age Gilded Age really the peak of the
Industrial Revolution the people who had
most of the leverage were the owners of
capital the growth industries as we said
before these were railroads these were
manufacturing plants these were people
exploring and finding oil and so capital
had all of the leverage that the labor
most of the labor that was involved was
fairly unskilled and was viewed by the
owners of capital as something of a
commodity and so more and more of the
outcome or the income could go to the
capital now Piketty at least hints that
hey maybe we're going into a second
guilded age because returns on capital
are going to be larger than growth and
more and more wealth is going to be
going to that but I do a thought
experiment once again this does give you
food for thought and and you come up
with your own conclusions let's think
about the world that we now live in and
I'll give Silicon Valley's an example
because one could argue that Silicon
Valley is maybe most indicative of what
21st century with the 21st century
economy is going to look like and what
21st century industry is going to look
like so let's compare the Gilded Age to
silicon silicon valley home of folks
like Google and Facebook and Apple well
in Silicon Valley is it about capital or
is it about labor
well the industries in Silicon Valley
they're about creating technology
they're about creating software software
in particular requires very very little
capital you don't need large
billion-dollar manufacturing plants you
don't need a ton of land you literally
can write software and you
or bedroom you could you could you could
do it in your closet that's that's how I
started and so Silicon Valley is really
much more about labor now it's not labor
and we know when you think of labor in
the Gilded Age Industrial Revolution
you're thinking about someone just
working on a factory line or doing a
repetitive job over and over again well
in Silicon Valley it's much more about
highly skilled labor so let me write
that in that blue color highly highly
skilled highly skilled labor and it's
definitely the case in Silicon Valley
that highly skilled labor is viewed as a
much much stronger differentiator for an
organization or an individual than
capital in fact the dynamics that you're
seeing more and more in Silicon Valley
is lots and lots and lots of capital
which is oftentimes perceived as a
commodity pursuing a team of five people
who have just put something together in
the last few months and they're valuing
it at ten million dollars or 50 million
dollars we see organizations like
Facebook and whatsapp getting multi
billion dollar valuations based on
really the output of highly skilled
labor capital there's some capital
necessary you need office space you need
servers but it's not like the Gilded Age
most of the value is and the the part
that's not considered a commodity office
space is a commodity the server's are
commodity highly skilled labor is not a
commodity so the question to ask
yourself is well this is this the case
and is this the case will will capital
will R be able to stay larger than G and
will more and more capital accumulate go
more and more in a highly skilled labor
now the other question you need it or
the other question that might be going
in your might as well hey look Silicon
Valley isn't just about software it's
also about hardware most one of the most
highly successful companies in Silicon
Valley is Apple computers and they do
write software but they're known for
their hardware products that their
iPhone the iPad their their computers
what about that industry isn't that
capital intensive well let's just think
about how how your iPhone or your iPad
gets developed it gets designed
I Apple & Cupertino California and
that's what they write on their box is
designed in California and then they
send the designs over to a bunch of
firms this is just some of some of
Apple's suppliers here and these are
incredibly capital intensive industries
but from Apple's point of view they view
them more or less not all of them some
of them have differentiated products
they make a special type of material or
whatever else but many of them are
viewed as commodity manufacturers that
hey you don't give me the right price
you're not giving me the right few
pennies per component I'm going to go to
the other person who can produce that
same entity and then these folks put it
all together manufacture the pieces send
it back to Apple who will package it and
then and then market it and so what is
the high-value aspect of this supply
chain right over here well it's clearly
the design in the market and if you
don't believe that you should look at
what portion of the output of the income
generated by an iPhone what portion of
it goes to Apple versus what portion of
it goes to the the suppliers right over
here so one way to think about it is
these these are kind of closer closer to
you know the the large scale capital
intensive manufacturing plants of the
Gilded Age although even here R&D plays
a major component that did in the Gilded
Age as well and once again R&D though is
a is a labor is a is highly highly
skilled labor it is less about there is
capital definitely involved but when you
look at the real value created it's
really on the highly skilled labor part
on designing and the marketing side the
creative aspects of it now just this if
you believe it and you should come to
your own judgments this by itself
doesn't say that we can't worry about
inequality because even this might say
look more and more income maybe it's not
going to go to capital it's going to go
to more and more highly skilled labor
and that's a small subset one could
argue of the entire labor pool you have
this highly skilled labor here and so
you might have inequality not happening
like it happened in the Gilded Age where
it's going to owners of capital but now
it's going to the owners I guess you
could say of highly highly skilled labor
and so
that could drive inequality but this is
where the force of convergence that
Piketty talks about could play in and he
seems a little bit skeptical of its
ability to overweight the forces of
capital accumulation but if we can have
more people participate in this more
highly skilled labour then potentially
this could be a of convergence it could
balance balance things off and keep us
from going into some type of neo Gilded
Age